there's a whole bunch of big money
industry financial players that will
happily pay 25 000 50 000 100 000 a year
just to be like uh explain this to
me
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could
[Music]
sean what um what are you wearing
you get so offended when i don't have
sleeves i forgot i'm not offended
like shook
you're completely flabbergasted
i think that a sleeveless hoodie is an
interesting choice i think it look you
look nice and then you look jacked
thank you i'm trying to be jacked
are you
um
i'm like thick jacked uh like i have a
lot of muscle but they're still fat on
the muscle so it doesn't look very good
i um i took this so i got you know you
know those cars that kids get where it's
like
it's like a mini version of a car so
they can drive it around like whatever
yeah
so we got one for my daughter's birthday
it's like a little mini range rover
thing and so i posted on instagram i
never post on instagram so i posted
instagram like a close-up of like the
range rover logo the wheel where you it
couldn't you couldn't tell it's like a
kid's car i was like yeah a new ride you
know work hard it always pays off
and then i posted like a zoomed out
version of it in my driveway and it's
like two feet long and then i took a
picture posing with it and then uh and
then yeah i didn't realize that i forgot
that most of the world hasn't seen me in
like
two years um and so
you know i have long hair now i never
had long hair so everybody in my
instagram's like what the what's going
on is this you what is this and then uh
also i've gotten like considerably like
bigger and more muscular i guess yeah
you're you're you've you've over the
last i would say four years
four years it's been like a three year
journey maybe you've changed
significantly
yeah yeah so i i got a bunch of dms of
people just being like well like like
how that's funny what you were doing
like because i was like you know like
you know proving the haters wrong like
you know hard work pays off you know
like the cringy instagram stuff that
people do when they like get a new car i
was doing that i just doing it for a
joke and then also jokes on me because
people are like you look weird
that's all right they're actually
complimenting you so do you know that um
i was reading stuff on we talked about
examine.com i was reading about
examine.com so i i enjoy reading about
things that have core or that are
correlated to longevity
um and so like different studies on that
and so there's two findings that i've
discovered the first is grip strength so
grip strength is highly correlated with
longevity
the second thing is
yeah i'll explain why
and the second reason or the second
thing is quad strength so your thighs
how strong your thighs are now so you're
living until 300 300.
yeah i think i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
old
however
there's not a correlation between muscle
size
and longevity so just because you have
big muscles doesn't necessarily mean
that you're gonna live a long time but
what it means is grip strength and quad
shrinks are both really um the most uh
perfect of an imperfect test to test
your upper body and lower body strength
and so if you're strong you're going to
live to be longer or it's it's more it's
correlated with longevity
so strength is so i think it's good
you're lifting weights
uh yeah but i feel like my grip strength
and quality is not great and i also feel
like that's not what the show is and
nobody cares about my griffin quad
strength but i do think it's cool the
longevity thing is cool i've been i've
been like
you know you have these things where
you're like okay i'm not doing a project
in this area it's not my work it's not
my job
i also don't even really know what i'm
looking for but i just keep going down
this rabbit hole
just i just keep watching videos or
reading stuff or kind of like talking to
people about this thing i kind of
i don't have like a destination i'm
trying to get to
and um that's what it's been with this
uh longevity anti-aging stuff i've just
been watching a ton of interviews and
reading about a bunch of the science
about what's
what is the latest in this space i think
i talked about it on the podcast that
guy i regret
degrade yeah and uh and then there's
like laura deming do you know who she is
no
so she's um
she's a
i don't know she's an entrepreneur i
think she's kind of like
she she started doing this when she was
like 16. i think she was a teal fellow
so she dropped out of college
uh to take the teal fellowship which was
basically peter thiel made this thing
where's like i'll give you a hundred
grand if you just drop out of college
and um
work on whatever project you want to
work on so he's paying people to drop
out and so she took that and she was
like okay do i start a company do i do
this do this and i think she ended up
creating something called i think it's
called the longevity fund
and it's basically it was the first
major i don't want to say first it was
one of the first at least major vc funds
that was like
um
only investing in anti-aging and
longevity companies and so she raises
money she's still probably i don't know
under 25
and um but she's like you know a veteran
in this space now so i think she worked
under armor de gray and then i think she
uh or knows him at least and then she's
got this longevity fund and she was
talking about like
you know what's what's been
what gives her hope like what what
breakthroughs or advancements make her
think oh shoot like the products are
really being made and like
what are some things where
10 years ago you thought this would be
here by now and we're still 10 years
away or more and uh and i feel like
there's a bunch of space like
self-driving cars is like that people
have been thinking about this for a long
time or vr people have been thinking
about it for a long time it always feels
like it's five years away but it never
hasn't clicked yet but you do feel like
it's inevitable and that's kind of like
what anti-aging is
yeah i've been reading it a bunch one of
my favorite books is it's like the the
pop culture version of all those blue
zones have you read blue zones no what
is that you don't know you don't know
what the blue zones is no blue ocean i
know but not uh all right so the blue
zones is fantastic so it's a book that
studies five different cultures that
have an incredibly high number of
centarians so a large population of
people who are above 100 years old i
believe the five locations are the
seventh uh the seven day adventist which
is a religious crew in
mid california then there's a group in
japan there's a an area in greece an
area of
korea and i maybe costa rica i forget i
forget the other ones and he tries to
narrow down to the handful of things
that they all do and those things
include eating meat and vegetables
particularly large amounts of vegetables
drinking moderately
not exercising vigorously but exercising
like walking to work or walking around
all day so the seven-day adventists
they um they they believe their body's a
temple and so they walk throughout the
day and they work jobs where they got to
lift stuff above their head but they
don't exercise in the traditional sense
they don't damage their body to try to
get super sore and grow the muscles
yeah and they and they under eat you
know they don't overeat because they
believe that their body is like sacred
um
and then a few others are the old folks
don't go to living
nursing homes they stay at home so they
have a stronger sense of community
typically they drink moderately i also
believe a lot of them have some type of
religion or spiritual thing that they're
like looking towards
um and uh that's mostly it but there's a
maybe a few more characteristics that
they all share
and do you um there's a whole bunch of
like drugs that are like you know
possibly
possibly linked to longevity like
whatever metformin and stuff like that
have you dabbled in any of those
no but i'm as of today for the past
handful of months i've been taking a
variety of magnesium
um what ashwagandha the thing that you
mentioned right um
what's it called althea
it's one of those
it's one of those words that like i
write all the time but i never
pronounced
theanine yeah
cava
uh and i believe that's it but i've i
i've i have been interested in some of
that stuff i just haven't what's it
called again it's called um
i forget the stuff that that's proven in
my mice for longevity
uh i don't know rap some myosin or
something like that rapamycin
yeah
um anyway uh so uh yeah i'm interested
in longevity stuff we'll have to talk
about it i i don't have slack open by
the way if you're gonna message me i
don't have slack open i've got zen
caster no i was just kidding like some
of the things we were talking about
yeah they're all it's all meant for like
lower mood also the blue oceans a lot of
it a lot of it um they have low stress
right
yeah i think this stresses that stress
is the killer that's that's what some
people talk about with warren buffett
because buffett's diet is like famously
garbage
like soda mcdonald's yeah he like i
think he eats uh you know mcdonald's for
breakfast every day on his way to work
or something like that
like a sausage mcmuffin every day i
remember watching some video following a
day in the life this was like 10 15
years ago so maybe he's uh maybe he's
he's sharpened up but at the time he was
saying this is what he does every single
day and then he drinks diet cokes and he
eats eminem's it's like all his
portfolio companies you know that he
like lives by basically
and um
and so you know it's like shocking but
because he's you know he's in pretty
good health and he's got like he's got
his wits about him even though he's
almost 90 years old or whatever he's
like very sharp mentally has high energy
that sort of thing and obviously he's
still performing like extremely well at
his job even at that age and so um so a
lot of people are like well that defies
the odds and then some people say well
one thing that buffett does right he may
do a lot of dietary things wrong but one
thing he does right is he is
extremely low stress
and um
and it's uh if i was betting i would bet
that stress ages and hurts you more than
any other
um like dietary input now i'm not a
scientist it's just like my observation
of people i could see people who are
glowing who have high energy people who
stay healthy and who don't and it's like
if i looked at what in my life the
people around me
what would be the common denominator um
it's actually not their diets it's more
of their their stress and their mindset
yeah i uh
it's it's it's hurt me in the past so
we're on the same page do you um
do you want to talk about the results of
the nft thing
yeah dude i mean it's kind of insane we
uh so
we did this nft auction which was uh uh
here's like the the quick summary if you
if you didn't follow so basically
i was i'm really into crypto i did this
thing called crypto week where i was
just deep diving and my goal was to
actually use all the different parts of
crypto not just like be an investor but
like be a be a user of what they call
web3 which is all these different
technologies different things you can do
one of which is nft so i bought some
nfts i i played with the tools to help
you value them or scope them out and all
that stuff and the last thing i did was
i wanted to mint an nft and i thought
all right what would be an nft i would
do well we're not great artists so i'm
not gonna you know
i'm unlikely to have this
visual art that just speaks to you
um but i was like what did we do well
and i thought well one thing we've done
is we've we've created this audience
through my first million and what if we
created an nft called five minutes of
fame
and five minutes of fame is real simple
it basically just says hey
the owner of this nft owner of this
token it's like the willy wonka golden
ticket if you have this golden ticket
you get access to the chocolate factory
so for us it was if you own this token
you get access to the pod you get five
minutes of air time on the pod where you
could talk about whatever you want if
you wanna talk to us and just shoot the
bring your ideas to the table
fantastic if you wanna ask questions or
promote your company or whatever you
wanted to do that five minutes it's
yours and
so kind of on a whim i just texted you
being like hey idea what do you think
you're like cool go for it
and uh i minted it on open c so i paid a
little bit of uh ethereum to create it
i set up an auction for seven days and i
started the auction at .25 ethereum or
ether uh and so that was the equivalent
of at the time about like 700 800
and it just closed last night
at midnight the auction closed and i
think it made 33 000 so i think it
closed at 11.55
which is about about 30 32 33 000
i think it was a little more let's see
11.5 times
11.5 five three thousand five
35 grand
yeah so that was uh that's what it
closed at last night and uh
so we should shout out the winner
i thought it was gonna go at about 25
30k that's right that's what i would
have predicted ads on how much would an
ad cost on this podcast maybe
10 000 and we would do a couple of them
yeah i think you know 10 000 bucks would
would be you know maybe i don't know we
don't sell ads anymore so i don't know
what five or 10 grand maybe going ad
rate would be for it but you can't we
don't sell them so you can't even get it
but yeah who's the winner
um the winner is
his username just like d2d something so
i don't actually know the person um you
know it's sold to uh kind of an unnamed
unnamed artist
they can they can hold it so they can
basically say all right cool y'all are
growing 20 month over month i'm in no
rush
let me um let me just hold this for you
know the foreseeable future and um
and let's let this thing grow and then
you know they could cash it in later or
um so the username the one person you
want is d2d d2d628
and then you can go look at their
profile about some other stuff that they
own they own some other nfts that are
you know five e three eth they own one
that's valued at 335 each so they
definitely have like a portfolio
that they collect
335 i mean that's like is that 900 000
yeah it's like a million dollars that's
the set price for it i don't know if
that's what it'll go for but that's the
um wow that's the the list price that
that's asked um so anyways this person
won and they can sell it so they can
just say cool i'm gonna flip it they can
use it
the way they use it is they send it to
our wallet so they'll have to burn it by
sending it to our wallet which takes it
out of circulation
and um and that's how we know you were
the owner of it and you cashed it in
all right let's um you want to talk
about some you want to talk about
harvard
yeah we talked about this we hinted at
it last time so let's do it i think you
did a bunch of research
yeah but i want you to you i want you to
kick it off and explain to me why you uh
got interested in this basically i i've
known about this for a while so i
launched trends because i read all about
this and so i want to know what caught
you i i think i brought this up on the
podcast a little bit but what caught
your eye you initially told me about uh
the harvard business review in passing
you just said something very
very you're like i think they do like
100 million dollars you said something
like that and um so that caught my eye
this was maybe five years ago
and at that time i like kind of stashed
that away and then when we sold bebo one
other thing i did a brainstorm of like
when i started another thing
and one of the things that always
interested me was education education
education education i was like okay well
i like business i mean this is before
the podcast even i was like i really
like business and kind of digging into
nerdy business stuff
could i package that into a product it
became this podcast but one of the ideas
i had was
could i compete with
harvard business schools hbr kind of
their media arm because what they do at
the time i was looking into their case
studies so what they do is
if you ever go to business school
and there's many business schools that
do this they have kind of like
case-based learning project-based
learning basically and so you you go
into class and you get this printed out
piece of paper that says here's the
scenario you're the ceo of sony and
you're coming up at the new playstation
and you're competing with xbox and right
now sony's market share is going down
and you need to figure out a way to get
it to go up here's some of the
background and it basically gives you a
case to walk through and basically give
your kind of like your two cents on what
you think the strategy should be and all
that good stuff and then the teacher has
kind of like an answer key essentially
it has the results of how things played
out and what worked what didn't and kind
of a guided discussion and so it's
basically like the curriculum for a
business school so i the reason i got
interested in this because i was
actually going to go start a company
making these case studies focused on
technology focused on on kind of like
cutting-edge tech and either sell it to
schools or sell it to companies who
wanted to train their managers so that
was my like
idea i still kind of want to do that
someday
but i did back away from it when i
realized
that harvard really had a monopoly i
think the stats at the time were that 80
of all the case studies all the business
school case studies were harvard
business school case studies and then
the second thing was if you go talk to a
professor i think i talked to two and i
was like hey i'm gonna do all these
great case studies it's gonna be so much
better
and they're like
yeah but like uh what's that phrase like
no nobody gets fired for buying ibm it's
like nobody gets fired for buying the
harvard harvard case study if i go by
the sean case study um and if if
anything is off about it um
or even if it's good like it's just
gonna have lower perceived value than
the harvard one so actually i need to
stick on the harvard sauce
and i was like oh that's a problem it's
the credential it's the brand of harvard
not the content of the case study that
really makes a difference so let me set
the stage here and give some numbers to
explain what we're talking about okay so
every number i'm going to tell you is
from 2019. all of these numbers are
public so this isn't this isn't ideas or
theories or
rumors this is fact
in 2019 harvard business school made
925 million dollars i'm going to rank in
order where that revenue came from so 25
or uh yeah 25 percent right which around
it jump billion basically just to make
the math easy yeah well i absolutely we
don't do public math 25
or around 250 million dollars came from
endowment in gifts okay
that's the second largest thing i'm
gonna save the first largest for last
the third largest thing 24
or around 240 million dollars executive
education tuition we made from tyra
banks for saying she went to harvard
because she went to an executive
education that's what she's talking
about
the fourth largest thing get this only
15 percent of revenue
mba tuition right
tuition is the fourth largest one
the final two are harvard business
school online so basically online
courses which is five percent of revenue
and then finally housing rents and other
three percent so the biggest one their
biggest revenue stream is 28 roughly 280
million dollars
that makes almost two times what tuition
makes what is that
they're publishing arm
right so they make money in publishing
through a couple different ways
basically a uh uh two or three they make
a little bit of money through
advertising but it's pretty it's nominal
but they have 400 000 subscribers and
subscribers pay anywhere from 10 to 50 a
month depending on which package you get
but the bulk of their revenue comes from
the 15 million case studies they sell to
around 4 000 universities now that
number of around um
let's say i think i believe the exact
number is 262 million dollars in revenue
how does that rank so let's put this in
in
in um
perspective here the new york times i
think probably the largest print
publication or text-based publication in
america revenue of 1.8 billion the
economist another 100 plus year old
brand 429 million harvard business
review 262 forbes
which has you know all they do is
publishing 180 million fortune 100 and
axios 58 million however amongst all of
those harvard business review has the
highest
revenue per employee so they're the most
efficient so 582 000 per employee so
that that's some of the numbers
shockingly big shockingly big
it's shockingly big and uh so just to
break that down into kind of the
different categories so let's focus on
hbr so what are their products they have
the
they have the the review they publish
which is kind of like a magazine right
essentially it's like a
sort of like a smart kind of smart
person magazine then they have the case
studies what's the split between those
uh case studies and subscriptions
yeah
uh well they sell uh about 15 million to
20 they they sell like 18 million case
studies a year and they cost like uh 10
to 20 dollars a piece so if we round uh
here i actually have the exact numbers
they have um
400 000 subs and they sell 18 million
case studies uh so i would imagine that
of the 262 million dollars uh 200
million is from case studies
wow um yeah so that's kind of
unbelievable and that's basically
recurring revenue because they're they
have to pay for it each year
yeah the way it works is your professor
who's teaching so professors who are
teaching at any mba they basically the
the one of the four thousand
universities in america they've given
harvard their credit card and the
professors just scroll through and they
go click i want that oh i have 120
students therefore 120 times 20 that's
how much i'm going to pay just click and
bill it to the university and that's how
it works right
yeah i still want to compete with this
actually now that you've brought this up
again it just makes me want to go do
this um so i i tweeted this out um
i put this in my newsletter actually uh
yesterday i go top universities are an
amazing business imagine having hundreds
of millions in recurring revenue through
tuition or publishing
a huge a huge like venture capital fund
basically a huge fund not venture
capital a huge fund which is their
endowment you own your real estate and
you pay virtually no taxes because
you're a non-profit and so like i think
harvard paid
i remember reading this one year they
paid um
12 million dollars in federal taxes
on all that revenue that you said um
because uh because they're you know a
501 with a 3c or whatever it is they're
basically like you know they're a
non-for-profit university and i think
they just there was just some new bill
that like now they have to pay some tax
on their endowment so their bill went up
to like 50 million which is still you
know not very much for you know a
billion dollar bill billion dollar a
year um enterprise and well so check
this out dude harvard's endowment is 40
billion dollars so let's just say that
they get a seven percent return so
that's a little bit less than four
billion dollars
right that they get an annual profit i
would have to run the numbers but i
believe i did this one time if they gave
free tuition to all of their students
and they only paid their bills with
their endowment profits they would still
net make a profit of a few hundred
million dollars a year so like you have
to keep in mind that harvard like you
say you want to compete with harvard
okay cool i hear you they have
not infinite but close to as many res as
much resources as you could ever
possibly need to to build
yeah so so what is harvard worth right
like if you were going to value harvard
how would you value harvard
the same as nike or something like that
i mean you have to look at what the
multiples are for nike and interestingly
if we did do if we just looked at the
harvard business review revenue harvard
business review had 262 million dollars
in 2020 revenue if we added the same
multiple that the new york times
currently has it would be worth just the
business school portion would be worth
1.2 billion dollars
yeah oh sorry just the publishing arm of
the business school
right so just the publishing arm the
media company would be 1.2 billion um
would be valued valued at that right is
that what you said
yes
and so uh the whole thing is probably 50
billion or more
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's a lot and you
one would argue that they're not exactly
optimizing to make revenue and profit i
mean i i don't i don't know
too much about it but i would have to
imagine that they're not like you know
smacking the whip and telling everyone
like you know we gotta improve margins
right
[Laughter]
uh yeah it's kind of crazy so um
and let me give you some more stats you
know mit tech revie
you'll see them floating around i
recruited a person from mit tech review
to work at the hustle and that person
told me all about it and they were doing
north of 20 million in revenue and it's
archaic it's a very very old enterprise
um colombia has a a popular one
university of virginia is the second
highest
sale of case studies and get this here's
another big one you know oxford press
have you heard of the
oxford university press they own the
oxford review and they make books so
they do close to a billion a year in
sales
wow
from their book publishing from their
book publishing yeah and case studies
but lots of books all right so how would
i do this sorry let's let's brainstorm
with me so i think people get the idea
that hey these are much bigger
businesses than you would you would have
thought
what would you do if you wanted to go
get some of this action if you said wow
that's a lot of money being spent on
let's just start with let's just take
case studies well look you're stressed
you're advising your buddy sean sean
says you know what i think i want to do
this but i don't have the angle
what would you what would you say
so i did this dude so my company trends
the ones that i just sold we did this at
the end of this year trends will
potentially be a 10 million plus a year
recurring revenue business
so we did do this we built this exact
thing and if i owned it and was trying
to make as much revenue as possible i
would start in knowing what i know now i
would charge probably 10 times the price
so i probably charge 20 or 30 000 a year
well
10 to 30 000 a year and i would start in
different niches and i would slowly
start checking off the box and i would
build this elite kind of
scary brand you know something like a
viacom or a blackstone something that
has this like or like uh
uh what's the university that starts the
d darth dartmouth like something like
kind of like cool sounding um i think um
what's the what's the um research report
okay here we go
yeah our you know gartner we'll just
call it like uh uh uh like uh i don't
know i would have to look around and
just like you know it's like your porn
star nickname i'd be like your favorite
piece of furniture right and you're like
the hardest the hardest metal or rock
surface near you okay granite
and then like uh
you know you know a word that means
research
yeah we're gonna call it like macklin
inc like the street that i grew up on
macklin inc
and you start doing these like and you
start do you hire sales people you know
you do build like a gardener and then i
would branch down and start hiring a few
more pop culture centric writers
and uh then i would and i would do a
little bit more broad a little bit more
broad one but you know this is what
gartner did and gardner's has a
significantly large business um
and so that's what chrysonomics do this
too you know about them
they tried to but they didn't execute
that well that doesn't mean the business
sucks but they failed at executing it i
think they ran out of steam or lost
interest
i see okay and what um you you sold to
basically small business freelancers
entrepreneurs agency owner types yeah
dude and we have like you know over 20
or i don't you know tens of thousands of
subscribers okay and we did that well
but i'm an idiot because the reality is
those same people would have spent a
thousand dollars right now they spent
three hundred dollars
and so i up the pricing i should
have charged either way more or way less
so another way is i should have charged
a hundred dollars or 99
and made that an impulse buy 300 which
is what we charge that's not an impulse
buy 99 is so you charge 99 for a couple
small things then you have an upsell of
two three four five thousand dollars and
very few people buy that but you use the
99 dollar one as a get in the funnel
that's what you should have done i did
2.99 that's that was a dumb so you you
you have two two things you would have
done differently one is the price point
and then the other you're saying is you
would have niched into certain
categories
and like really built those categories
out what would what would be the first
two or three categories
oh i would probably uh let's see i mean
it would have to be like what i know so
i bet i could have done media pretty
well i also think i could have done d to
c and what i could have done is i could
have gotten like the nikes of the world
to give me twenty thousand dollars a
year and they would have gotten two
things one i would have published one or
two case studies a month maybe four or
five case studies a month on the latest
and greatest ecom um
like the d2c folks like who's who and
who in the category is is crushing it
why are they crushing it and then every
single month i would host a digital or
sometimes in person panel where i would
go out and find uh you know the sean the
sully and the ramone or the is like you
know three or four young young companies
that are crushing it and then all these
gray-haired nike executives would want
to come in and be like oh that's how you
guys are doing it that's how you're
thinking about x y and z and i would do
that panel once a month and uh you guys
would get free access the young guys but
then the companies would have to pay 20
to 50 000 a year
and then here's the third thing that i
would do
i would come up with a very cute graph
or some type of signature thing where i
rank and i have a ranking so i have a
power ranking here's all the power
rankings of the latest and greatest d2c
brands that are under eight years old
here's the best up and coming ones here
are the incumbents the older guys here's
the their power rankings and i would
create some
it wouldn't be it would be some
type of legitimate ranking but i would
come up with some proprietary thing and
that's how my ranking would be and i'll
keep that updated at all times right
uh yeah i agree and i think you could do
this right now in crypto that was a
great idea by the way the idea
was great it was great that would
work that will work
yes it was an absolutely great idea now
i think you could do this in other
spaces so i think you could do this in
crypto why because there's a whole bunch
of different brands yeah
there's a whole bunch of big money
industry financial players that will
happily pay twenty five thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars a year just to be like
uh explain this to me and tell me
whatever would be way easier crypto
would be way easier to sell than d2c
because crypto is fear based so you want
anything that's fear based exactly and
it goes after the biggest wallets uh
people who people who like it's one
thing to say oh these brands are
crushing it but if you know which tokens
are crushing it which networks are
crushing it you can actually make money
off them and on the other side you're
afraid of them if you're the incumbents
that have huge wallets so i think that's
why it's better
additionally with crypto you've got all
these guys like shawn and jack butcher
who are spending 24 hours a day on
discord and twitter and like studying
and they're like oh kevin rose just
tweeted this out and then you have some
gray hair guy at morgan stanley they're
like why do i care what kevin rose does
and what the is discord and you're
like yes exactly forget about it
i'm just gonna spoon feed this to you
like big name influencer just tweeted
this likelihood of it getting big pretty
high right you know what i mean yeah for
sure um
yeah so i think i think that's uh that's
something by the way if somebody does
this let us know there's a guy who
reached out i gotta show you this
there's somebody who reached out that
said hey you guys were talking a while
back i think i came on the pod one day
and i had this idea i was like
somebody needs to do bar stool for tech
and um this person reached out and
they're like hey you had this idea a
while back
i want to do it i'm actually pretty
uniquely qualified to do it and he
explained why like i did this i did this
and i did this if anybody can pull this
off it's me and i'm like actually that's
actually pretty believable and um and so
i'm gonna like kind of help this person
you know think it through and maybe
maybe launch this thing so i'm gonna
share that with you but i love when
ideas come to life with a legit operator
by the way i also hate the exact
opposite
hey
i love that idea
would love to talk to you about it
no no thanks yeah i'm just like just
zero appeal in that one
yeah i think it's far more appealing to
someone say oh i've been working on this
for three months i've made fifteen
thousand dollars so far exactly okay
let's talk i have a stock reply now
which is like hey uh glad you like the
idea
you know would love to support but i i
get a bunch of dms all about the same
idea every time we release one of these
so my rule is basically if somebody
shows me that they're actually like
there's a lot of people who talk about
it very few people who do things
if you end up doing something actually
building a product getting some users or
making some money definitely hit me up
that'll get my attention and i'll
happily help then but just for you know
peace of mind i can't help everybody who
just says that's cool i'd love to think
about it dude that's so much nicer i'd
just say let me know when you have
traction
that's usually what i say i also if
someone comes to me saying they're
considering working on x y and z or they
say this was amazing i'm starting to
work on it and then a month later they
say this is amazing i'm starting to work
on this other thing i say oh you are
disqualified right you no longer think
of him
yeah you're one of them people
you have no grit i do not want to talk
to you about uh if you jump from idea to
the project to project to project and
you don't without like a really really
good reason yeah you're done yeah i just
have to i'm super guilty of that but i
understand why you feel that way and i
think you're correct um
okay let's do some let's do some other
let's do some other topics um
let's see what else you got what you got
something else you want to do
no you lead you got something well i see
this amazing thing i kind of want to
talk about that and then there's another
one
let's let's do actually
i think this one's more this one's
funnier uh the topic on our sheet says
maybe don't fake it till you make it
it's like
it's timely right so um
i tweeted out i retweeted this story of
this guy who was like hey you know the
the elizabeth holmes the founder of
theranos her trial starts today
funny story i actually interviewed at
their nose after all the scandal
happened so that i thought that was kind
of interesting because a lot of people
that were like oh yeah i met her back
when everybody thought they were hot
it was a 10 billion dollar startup
and she was the next steve jobs and i
had this funny experience this guy's
experience was
all the news had come out and then a
smart mentor of mine was like hey you
should take a look at this role at their
notes like this high-level exec role
he's like they're joking and they're
like no no like you know it's
misunderstood and she's amazing you
should talk to him and then like another
person said he's like okay i guess at
least i'll get a good story out of this
so he flies there and he interviews with
her and he like kind of tells this story
i don't remember all the details it was
an entertaining story
you can find it on twitter and uh
actually you can't because twitter
search sucks but like yeah just take my
word for it it's an entertaining story
so
the the topic here is like there's been
a bunch of these i feel like that have
like happened in the tech world lately
and i think in the tech world there was
this gospel of
fake it till you make it yeah that's
that's the cool way to go about things
that's the hustler way
and then you see things like ferret
theranos you see nikola motors which was
like
this like fake tesla basically literally
like took the name right like tesla was
the inventor's last name nicola was his
first name so tesla was successful so he
names his company nicola
and uh he claims that that's not why he
did it but obviously it is why he did it
um takes the company public via a spac
it runs up to this like 40 billion
dollar valuation and then somebody's
like hey bro have you ever seen a nikola
car on the streets
and like no nobody's ever seen a truck
of theirs
ever
and it's a questionable if it even
exists they have like one video of their
truck and it's basically like just going
downhill it's like they just had a truck
and they released the neutral the put it
in neutral and just let it roll and
they're like look
electric self-driving truck
and uh and so anyways you know
eventually the ceo trevor milton
uh has to resign
he forfeits some of his stock but he
gets away with billions still uh he's
but he's charged by the doj with
securities fraud this year and um
and so you know he's gotta still get at
his peak yeah like a 10 billion dollar
fortune now it's a one billion dollar
fortune but likely to lose it all
my buddy worked at this company called
head spin and was like he was like he
had worked at a bunch of i won't say the
name so i don't want to give him away
but you know high profile tech company
you've heard of high profile tech
company you've heard of he worked at the
pre-ipo and then he was like i'm a head
spin this is the next one
and he sent me a investor deck for it
and it looked great i was like i should
invest in this company like it's a sas
company what headspin does is they like
uh if you have a mobile app and you want
to test it you want to see how does this
work uh on a shitty android phone in
thailand on low network conditions well
like how are you going to sit in your
office in san francisco and test that
they basically had phones everywhere in
the world in these like little like data
rooms and they would run your app and
they would report back how your app runs
this is cool as a great idea
and they would give you performance
testing performance data benchmarked
against your competitors in every every
region on every phone on every every
cell network
and um
and so they're at the time in their deck
they had 100 million dollars of
recurring revenue it's like oh this is
clearly going to be a multi-billion
dollar company
uh fortunately i just for whatever
reason didn't invest i just got busy and
i forgot about it and um
it came out that the ceo had just
literally made it up so he's like just
making up the revenue numbers and uh so
he's you know charged with fraud the
company's kind of like you know in
disarray a little bit and uh he was just
reporting false revenue and like
telling all the kind of bookkeepers in
the company like you know they're on a
need to know basis about what they can
know and hey
if we're gonna raise money i need the
number to show this my take on this is
there's good news and there's bad news
here the good news is most people are
good and they don't lie
there's amazing things that i've done
just off a trust for example i've told
you this i bought a car one time i just
called the guy and i go hey you have it
i'll take it and he goes cool just send
me the money sent him the money and then
just like i was hoping that he was going
to deliver i do that all the time that
works most of the time
the bad news is is that these people
exist and it's very
easy to get away with this i mean get
away with it for a little while you know
most of time you're caught but it's
really easy to lie and it's to get away
with it for a while so
how many of your startups how many
startups have you invested in
uh maybe 40.
okay i've done probably 25 or 30. how
many of them could be lying to you think
and and like if
100 of them could be lying to me and i
would not know
and that's for two reasons i'll just
explain why
i'm going to be honest about this most
people are not honest about this but
great i didn't want to call you out and
i i do the same thing but i i didn't
want to call each other so i want you to
volunteer most investors myself included
do
zero due diligence we do not we meet the
founder yes we play with the product
right those are the two easy things we
we see if
you know i can use your product that
tells me something i can kind of just
check twitter see do people talk about
this is there good reviews about this
product whatever
and uh and i talked to the founder and i
just see uh
have you know
were they like you know a drug dealer
before this or did they work at google
right does the stuff they're saying add
up or are they saying things that just
like you said this number last time now
you're saying this other number which
one is it um but do i go audit their
financials no
do i um
audit their data room even if they send
they don't usually even send a data room
but even if they do do i go in there and
uh look at the numbers no even if i
looked at the numbers would i know that
these numbers are real no these are
they're self-reported no they're they're
they're oftentimes a photoshop of their
quickbooks
yeah exactly and i i don't know if you
mean photoshop as in uh edited or just
sorry um a screenshot of their
screen which could be photoshopped or
their analytics tool and it's like oh
what does active user mean it's like ah
it's a lot of effort to figure out what
the heck they're talking about here but
you know directionally i can see what
this is going so
i do so little diligence
most legit investors do so little
diligence we are all banking on the fact
that
there's some angels out there i mean
angel i mean i mean that's angel
investor i mean like good good person on
earth who actually does dig in
and i know some of them
they're rare and they only do it with a
few companies
um
i
i co-invest a lot with ankur from
teachable and he does diligence and
he'll send me ryan hoover does diligence
like when i meet with a founder usually
on the call within maybe 10 minutes i've
decided yes or no whether i'm going to
invest usually no but if it's yes it's
like i'm in in principle i'll even tell
them that
i don't want to confirm i want to sleep
on it but like i'm in in principle and
the i want to sleep on it is just
because i've learned the hard way that
like my impulse investing is not always
going to be the best so like there's no
harm in letting it cool off and just
digging in a little bit but like ryan
hoover i send a lot of deals to ryan
hoover he sends a lot of deals to me and
he always is like great we're going to
dig in and get back to you and that
means they go they talk to customers of
the product they use the product
themselves they look at competitors i
don't think they audit financials or
audit metrics or anything like that i
still don't think that they do that but
um but they do more diligence than
anybody than most other people i know
who go off of
cool
if you're saying this i trust that what
you're saying is factual and true and
that you are not uh you know essentially
lying and committing fraud
so this whole fake it to the maker thing
is what we're talking about and uh
my point here is
you it's so easy
it would be it would be totally easy to
do this
yes intellectually speaking it's
obviously you gotta go you gotta be you
gotta be up and you gotta be
willing to you know hurt folks but
intellectually speaking this is very
easy to do it's also easy to um
and by the way if you're smart even if
you looked into it it's easy to fake it
so like i remember one one company we
bought we did an investment in a
purchase of we um
looked at their google analytics we were
like okay you're saying you have this
much traffic let me see your google
analytics dashboards they send us access
we go in ourselves not screenshots we're
looking google analytics okay all looks
good
and then i don't remember how this came
out but we looked at the code of the
website
which again most investors don't even
know how to read the code let alone are
they going to take the time to go what
do they they put their anal they put
their analytics code on someone else's
website no they had it on this website
but they were multiplying it so they
just doubled every event so if it said
one user's here no actually two users
were here so they just inflated by 2x i
don't remember exactly if they just put
two pit two they told the pixel to fire
twice or they were doing something else
but it was a multiply by two on their
traffic and usage and i was like wow
like you know do i need to go read
the code or like you go use crypto am i
really gonna know how to audit the smart
contract no i don't know how to do that
a handful of people on earth know how to
do this and so there's a lot that
happens that is trust and there's a sort
of cost of doing business of getting
into business with liars the good thing
about silicon valley is
it's unlike crypto and unlike you know
some other other industries it is a
long-term players game you you see
repeat players in the game and so what
that means is your incentive to have a
good reputation matters now does it
fully matter
well no because if you could be adam
newman and you could walk away with i
don't know what he walked away with over
a billion dollars i think out of the
wework thing
and maybe his reputation is tarnished
but he's guys got a billion dollars now
right the size of the prize makes it
worth it to like flush your reputation
for some people sometimes but at the
early stages with early stage startups
where i invest um you your your
reputation matters more than what you
can walk away with financially from that
that round
additionally i think that you you can
actually screw your reputation but as
long as you have a reputation as someone
who turns one dollar into two dollars
regardless of how big of a piece of
you are you'll always be able to
convince someone to give you money for
example there's this guy named garbash i
believe he started a company called
radium one and blue lithium am i getting
all these names right that's amazing if
i am you got that one wrong uh
it was something like that i think i
think so
my sister worked for him so i know i
know this guy very well
so give give the background of this this
guy it's it's crazy fascinating this is
actually great
the guy's a young successful
entrepreneur i think his first thing was
like a he he got big in ad tech so he
did like a tech company he sold it for
like 200 million dollars and i think he
you know raised very little so i think
he owned a lot of that so he became 100
million
he goes on oprah oprah's like wow you're
amazing you're like a bachelor like wow
any woman would want to be with you he's
good looking
yeah he's like he's like you know has
some charm he's got a lot of confidence
i don't think he's a good look he's got
a lot of confidence he was very rich and
successful at a young age and he would
say very motivational things his
instagram was all about you can do right
like he was barack obama with the hope
poster on his instagram
so fast forward he does another another
ad tech company but things start to go a
little bit weird he ends up getting
busted so there's a corporate weirdness
and then there's a public weirdness most
people only know the public weirdness
the public weirdness is
he
got caught on tape
kicking his girlfriend or beating his
girlfriend he kicked her like 127 times
on tape basically he had kidnapped he
was charged with kidnapping he wouldn't
let her leave the house like she was his
girlfriend she was there they got to
fight they got an argument and he he's
he's assaulting her and the cops
literally the footage is out there on
the internet you go see this now
cops take this footage he goes so he so
he gets fired as ceo of i think radium
one at the time or whatever whatever
kind of like new ad tech company he had
built that was like valued at 500
million to a billion dollars something
like that he gets kicked out of ceo
because like okay even though he hasn't
been charged yet dude there's a video of
you you know beating a woman on on the
internet like you're not the ceo anymore
and he's like i'm i'm innocent i don't
know how he tried to say i'm innocent
but he said trying to say i'm gonna say
basically so he goes to court he ends up
getting off because the footage was
collected improperly like they collected
the evidence uh in an improper way so
you couldn't use it so even though
everybody saw it everybody knew it
he ended up getting charged for like
uh kidnapping instead of assault or
something like that like it was like you
know something softer i i don't have all
the details right but basically i
remember there was some problem with the
way the evidence was collected
and so he goes you know has to do some
public service and rehab he goes lays
low for a bit but he comes back with a
new company uh gravity four i think was
the name of it
i think and do you know nick sharma yes
i think nick sharma what was his was was
that nick sharm nick sharma was his
assistant
i think sharma was like his chief of
staff i think i think it's his uncle
um if i'm correct like blood uncle i
think it's his blood uncle uh wow or
relative in some way i i hope i'm not
wrong on that but i'm pretty sure i am
so basically so here's some other kind
of inside stuff that i that i know
so then so he's building gravity for and
it's like in the ad tech space ad tech's
very competitive space so my sister
worked at a startup that was a different
ad ad network platform
they did like retargeting for a bunch of
big brands like booking.com and whatever
and they were doing all right but they
go and they start to pursue an
acquisition why because facebook's
always changing the rules and today
we're a preferred partner but tomorrow
facebook you know might give that out to
every agency or whatever my business is
very fragile i'm super dependent on
facebook and being one of these
preferred partners and so they go out to
sell the company and um i think they get
some good interest they get some offers
maybe it's from facebook google uh other
ad networks whatever it is
and uh gerbash wants to buy the company
so this is what i heard so you know uh
rumor
birdie tells me no no i can't confirm
any of this bertie tells me that he
hears about this he goes to bid on it
and he's a low bid uh he's not the
winning bit and they're also like dude
you're no way we would ever sell to you
um knowing what we know about you
and uh what he does is he goes and he
basically gets he tanks their their
prospects in the market how he basically
goes and spreads fear uncertainty and
doubt to the other bidders and he gets
facebook to pull their their access or
their privilege or whatever it was so he
somehow gets them basically like he
takes away their one like core business
asset and like just ruins their ability
to to sell the company and now they're
like short on cash can't go raise money
everybody knows they just tried to sell
the company and it flopped for some
reason and he goes and gets it for
pennies on the dollar and like has a big
falling out with the fact like you know
not on good terms it's not a happy sale
it was a fire sale and uh you know they
got something out of it because they
needed to get some value but like
against their good against their will
sell to gravity for it he's rolling up
these ad tech companies and from the
start he's saying in 18 months we're
going to take this public we're going to
go get 100 million dollars in revenue
we're going to take this public it's
like dude we have like no product we
have like no team you're just buying
these companies and we're supposed to
like integrate them like instantaneously
like you just bought five companies this
month that none of them like are
succeeding and they were supposed to
make them all work and this was after he
got caught this was after he got he got
arrested twice i believe twice for
beating two different women both i think
both caught on camera what like blatant
blatant
horrible crimes this was after right and
he's got like a bodyguard at the office
like this huge bodyguard that travels
with him everywhere he's got this like
model like supermodel like like a 12 who
just comes into the office and out
that's his new girlfriend i guess i
don't know what's going on there why
would anyone work for this guy after
completely erratic behavior and like on
one hand
like very ambitious inspiring and like
you're seeing your shares go from one
penny to he's saying we're gonna go
public at a billion dollars so you're
like oh okay we're gonna make i'm
gonna make 10 million dollars if i see
this out like i'm gonna make 25 million
dollars if i see this out like okay
maybe i should do that and the other
hand you're like this is a house of
cards like there's no like we we don't
actually have like a stable product we
haven't integrated all these
acquisitions the revenue is a little bit
flimsy because again like we're just
rushing this whole thing through and
then he got in trouble again and that
whole thing fell apart and i think he's
back now with another company like if
you go look him up i think he's back
again and that's my point which is you
can have a horrible reputation but if
you make money you will always be able
to get money and i'm not saying that's
good that's just what it is what did
your sister do for him
well she was at the company that got
acquired by him uh by his company so
then and so there was like a a temporary
period where like the whole company went
over there and then like i think within
six months there was not a single
employee left from the 40 that got
acquired or 50 i don't know how many was
like something like that there was like
one person left um
you know at the company by then why
would anyone choose to work for this guy
if they know that he is he's a piece of
that that amazes me like i don't
understand why you would continue to
trust someone like that yeah so now he's
doing something called vendor cloud he's
got he says on his twitter profile three
exits for 400 million dollars plus uh
philanthropist
and i think he i don't think he lives in
a i don't think he lives in america
anymore i think he like moved to
bangladesh or uh
which i forget where
it says um
hong kong
hong kong okay yeah
yes
he's going for it again i i don't know
and you know who knows who knows what
the other side of the story is i only
know one side of the story
and uh
yeah ben make sure i don't get sued from
this
bleep out whatever
everything that we just said is is just
a story and uh
a lot of it was factual but we
definitely could have gotten some of the
facts uh incorrect yeah exactly but the
story is like
the story is like eight years old maybe
or six years old it's not that recent
yeah it's pretty wild dude go watch like
the oprah video with him it's just it's
pretty crazy
yeah he was a a piece of so
that guy that's what i have to say about
that
that's a fact we tried taking a piece of
briefly we tried to edge so briefly
that it's like no dude that guy
like
i think like maybe i didn't get all the
facts right but i saw a video personally
yeah
my eyes saw this video
yeah my my opinion is go yourself
garbage or whatever his name is um all
right what do we want to do now we want
we want to wrap up or we want to do one
more uh let's do one more thing you got
anything quick
no
let me see one second let me look at my
little my little stash file here of uh
of i think did i talk about canva last
time dude
um just how it raised more money at a 40
billion evaluation or something yeah so
dude okay so check this out um
this is gonna be a bad segment because
it's really all i'm gonna say in this is
go read this go read this article but go
go read this article so what i want you
to do is just google
canva journey linkedin
um
so what what what happened was the
founder melanie perkins she uh posted on
linkedin
a kind of like she's pretty amazing
and when i say full history i mean like
details and i love details i love the
art of the start and so like i want to
share with you some of the things okay
so what's the story with canva canva
awesome product i use it it's basically
like it lets you design things like
marketing brochures infographics
ads banners emails whatever without
being a designer so you don't have to
have design skills they have enough
templates it's easy enough to just
change photos and colors and text that
like you'll get a good looking output
without being a designer
that's great because it brings a whole
new group of people into the world of
design all right so what's what's
interesting about this so first they
i think just raised a 40 billion
valuation uh which is insane it's one of
the most valuable companies to come out
of australia and
secondly this story is wild i actually
didn't know a lot can you link to it
link to it for me i don't like it
i'm just going to tell you about it and
then i'm going to i'm going to link to
it i want you to just just hear me hear
me tell it and then ask the story i ask
questions all right so so basically
um
she was i think a design t a teacher or
she was like teaching part-time at like
a uh
like a school for like design and art or
something like that
and um i think one the way they started
was actually not with a product called
canva it was with a
product called fusion books and all they
were doing was they're trying to solve
the problem of if you ever put together
like a yearbook or like a photo book
it's like very hard to like lay it out
and like oh i want this collage with
like eight photos but i need them to fit
right and then i want the background to
look pretty and have a flower and then
like you know page two i want it to be a
big picture and two small pictures
whatever right the layout of photo books
so they created
fusion books which is basically like
software slash like um
yeah software basically that that would
that would make that easy and so they
were like okay
um they like they got they got a little
money back from their tax return and
like their part-time jobs and they were
like all right that's our funding for
fusion books
and it's like you know you don't need a
year to make a yearbook do it in minutes
with fusion books and it's like the most
like non-impressive looking startup ever
and she doesn't just like what a lot of
people do when they tell the story is
they they what i say fast forward
through the hard part it's like yeah we
started with fusion books and then you
know through after a couple years we
started canva we realized canvas a
better opportunity and what canvas is
trying to do is empower design it's like
blah blah it's like wait what happened
to those two years so what i love about
this post is it actually talks about
those two years and so it's like a photo
of her at some like trade show with her
like fusion books yearbook thing and
she's standing there like a dork behind
the table no no people are at her booth
and she's like smiling and she's like
yeah this booth was a huge waste of
money because like there were more
exhibitors than attendees so that was a
flop
and then like she's like we didn't i
didn't know how to code and like we
didn't know how to find a technical
person and so it's just me and my
boyfriend trying to do this and like we
convinced this one part-time engineer to
do this but like here was the problems
and like here's our printer we're
literally printing books yearbooks for
people and dropping them off and we're
trying to go get every school to use us
blah blah blah all right so they start
doing all that
and so at one of these um
what's it called like i think it was
like either a competition or like you
know inventor of the year like uh
western australia inventor of the year
competition they come runner-up and
she's like you know i'm wearing this
dorky suit i'm holding this runner-up
prize but at that event i met this guy
named bill tai
and bill ty is like a kind of like a
famous investor in silicon valley he's
definitely famous now because he was the
seed investor of canva but he's done
many many big deals i think you can
probably google him and he's like he was
a vc who just like happened to be
speaking at the event
and he gets there and he's like oh you
know like they talk for five minutes and
he's like hey if you ever want to like
if you ever end up coming to silicon
valley like let's meet up and she's like
oh cool and then she does the thing this
is the fake it tell you make that
actually works it's not fraud till you
make it it's fake it till you make it
where she's like
uh wants to meet up with him but doesn't
want to be like hey bill i booked a
flight to fly from australia to san
francisco to see you so instead she says
we have to be there i happen to be there
this month like would you be free i
would love to chat and like if he says
yes then she'll book the flight and so
he's like um
he's like yeah sure you know happened to
me and you should also meet this guy
lars from facebook uh his ex google like
you know you should meet him and she's
like wow this is amazing and then she
posts every step of the way she posts
the full presentation that she made for
him which i love because
she released slide by slide the good the
bad the ugly like this one's like the
future of publishing dot dot is the
cover and it's like
fusionbooks.com.edu right it's like this
shitty thing oh my god and um it's like
she posts this pitch deck and like you
know she posts like five of them in this
blog post like you can see the evolution
all the way to canva
um
so she goes to meet with bill
and uh and so she's like uh
she's like google's like how to dress at
a silicon valley investor meeting it's
like you know just just get comfortable
you know just look smart casual you know
um you know you don't have to dress up
too much so she's like okay i'm not
gonna wear my like woman pantsuit
tracksuit thing i like my power suit
um she's like wore like you know
business casual and then she gets there
and he's like oh you don't you didn't
need to dress up for this by the way and
she's like i thought i was dressing
down she's like i'm i started off the
meeting just like totally mortified
and um
you know whatever and so then she's like
you know i presented him this pitch deck
and um
you know
um you know he's just like i'm
explaining the future publishing and
he's like cool like do you have a ipad
or an iphone she's like no you're like
you're telling me the future of
publishing and you don't own an ipad or
an iphone and she's like uh
but she shows this slide and her
thing and it's so funny dude you'll see
it when you when you get there so i'm
gonna send you the link now scroll down
to where you see this cartoon character
it's like clipart cartoon character
and it says fusion books and it's right
by the finish line and there's a trophy
at the end of the finish line that says
the dominant online publishing system
that's the trophy for winning and then
behind her you see two cartoon
characters of google docs and microsoft
office like falling behind falling over
and fighting each other and it's like
basically she's saying like we're gonna
beat google docs so we're gonna beat
microsoft word and so even at this point
where she had like terrible name
terrible design didn't know how to dress
didn't know how to pitch in oh my god
yeah didn't have an engineer she had the
like the um the thing that is like porn
to investors which is the ambition to
say
we're not just building yearbook
software we're gonna beat google docs in
microsoft office and like if you're
crazy enough to say that an investor
will listen to like the next three lines
you say to be like oh you're just
delusional or actually maybe this person
is crazy enough to pull something like
this off
so what was the turning point
so then she she hits uh so so there's
like a long period of time where um
where she's trying to find an engineer
so bill's like i'll invest in you
if you can bring on an engineer that
this guy lars this facebook google guy
i'm introducing you to he's an engineer
if he approves of the engineer i'll back
you because then i think you have the
software skills to pull this off so she
goes to lars she's like hey can you
introduce me some engineers
and he's like you know what like yeah
but it's hard to introduce your
engineers how about this if you find
engineers i'll screen them for you so
she finds like 20 engineers he screens
all of them and just thumbs down initial
screening and like no matter how
good she thinks the engineer is he's
like not even close and she's like oh my
gosh she's getting demoralized because
like bill's not going to invest unless
lara signs off on the engineer and lars
like i don't know what the hell he wants
but he's just not
signing off on any engineer and so this
goes on for like a year and so then she
like hustles like crazy bill ty is
famous for kite surfing she had like
kind of kite surf so she's like it
i'm going to become a kite surfer so
then she's like hey billy i was just
kite surfing and he's like oh you should
come to come kite surfing with me so she
like gets in with him again until like
oh my god
completely not the way i would advise
anyone to do this like just chasing one
investor like this but whatever this is
her journey
and uh
and so then she and then she posts this
thing where she like uh talks about it
she's like uh she's like i was so down
like as large as rejecting investor
engineer after engineering she writes
this note to herself and she posts it
she goes
mel
you're extremely tired you're in a
challenging situation though you could
pull through nothing bad is really
happening but you're feeling depressed
because you are used to achieving things
quickly this is a hard environment and
there's no doubt you will succeed you
will find the team that you need you'll
get the investment that you need and you
will build the company you always wanted
you have chosen to put yourself in a
challenging situation if it wasn't
challenging that you wouldn't feel
satisfied when you get to the end goal
and i love it like she was like you know
writing herself these pep talks and she
posted it which is like you know kind of
vulnerable to do
um
anyway she looks exactly the same now
like she's handled this woman she's a
ceo right yeah
so she's been through hell building this
business she looks
totally the same now it looks like the
stress did not bother her
that's crazy i'm looking at these photos
i'm like but in these photos are 10
years old she looks exactly the same
yeah i love this woman so she goes okay
so this so then she finally okay let me
just fast forward something she finds
the engine laura's like hey this guy is
like the best engineer i've ever worked
with you should uh you should hire this
guy she's like oh man amazing this guy's
already pre-screened so she talks to him
the guy's like interested
um
but he's like oh i got my own startup
right now and i have a team of six i
just can't do it so she just checks back
in like three months later she's like
hey
how about now and she checks back again
three months later he said hey babana
and one of those times he's like yeah
you know what let's do this and so he
says let's do this she's like oh that's
amazing blah blah blah
let me fast forward this story because
you should really just go read the post
but i have it up this is amazing there's
a whole bunch of things like she posts
every um
invest like a bunch of investor
rejection letters which is just like uh
sorry i just don't feel comfortable
investing in australia or like you know
would love to stay in touch um
it looks like we're gonna have to sit
and wait this one out or the valuation's
too high or
you know it's pre-launch or you know
whatever i don't think the timing is
quite right and she's just like you know
whatever we just kept kept going kept
going kept going and then um
and so she recruits this guy out of
google she like makes them google almost
retains them and she puts the
presentations like you know this is i
don't know his name but let's just say
sam's greg this is greg
he worked at google he had a great life
but he started to get bored started to
wonder is there more for me out there
and each one of these is one slide this
is like a little flip book it's like he
thought to himself what if i could go
and help you know a small team where i
could bring my expertise and do this
what if i could bring the power of
design to like a billion people on earth
what if i could do this wouldn't that be
better than just sitting at google for
another five years but then google said
oh we need you greg but then remembered
google's gonna keep googling whether he
goes there or not but canva may not if
if he doesn't join or whatever see you
know he makes his pitch and he's like oh
i love it you know you really like made
me feel special so like i'll do this so
i feel like it just showed a lot of the
grit and the hustle and it did not fast
forward
the ugly part to the point where i'm
like dude get to the canva part like
what is all this but it's like yeah
that's probably how it imagine if i'm
feeling amazing
imagine how she felt living this for
three years or whatever it is and then
yeah like you know they launch it it
takes off it's like you know super
successful and um you know it's a 40
billion dollar company now so happy
ending at the end of that one yeah and i
think her
i don't know if she was dating or if
she's now married after they started but
her and her co-founder are married and
so dating then married now i think so
it's pretty badass they have two times
the wealth now
um this is a good ass story i missed
this i don't know how you found this i
guess you found this on twitter uh it's
on linkedin which is funny at it and
somebody sent uh ishan who used to uh
who used to get my original podcast
because he's australian yeah he's
australian and i have him in a slack
channel with me still
and uh where we just post cool links and
so he posted this one he's like damn
this is actually really good this is
amazing this is a good find this is
totally badass all right that's it for
today
uh
good episode i think i know what do you
think how do you think that was dan how
was it the uh the harvard business stuff
is uh really cool i really liked that
segment
all right we'll see i think that was
well researched we'll see we uh we took
oh by the way we gotta give a shout out
to mario what's mario's last name
mario gabel or something like that
yeah he's actually i actually stole a
ton of information from him so good job
mario mario gabriel sorry
he's badass he has a the generalist is
his uh newsletter that's right so that
was awesome
all right that's it all right we're
outtie see
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back